[Musik]
wir haben das in den letzten fünf jahren
gesehen der stillstand hat einen namen
schwarz grün weil ich gezeigt habe dass
ich ein land führen kann in der sache
sehr erfolgreicher wir wollen natürlich
in hessen politik gestalten vor allem in
der wirtschaft der bildungspolitik und
der digitalisierung wir wollen die kluft
zwischen arm und reich schließen also
ich trete erst mal an um politik zu
machen in welcher funktion auch immer
meine erste amtshandlung wäre sofort das
thema bezahlbarer wohnraum anzugehen
nehmen wir wohnung zu mieten politik
brauchen wir veränderungen in der
bildung wir brauchen mehr
ganztagsschulen mehr lehrerinnen und
lehrer jemacht sorge dass an den rändern
es eine stimmung aufkommt die
unzufriedenheit dann auch in ablehnung
der demokratie um die afg in die
linkspartei mit den beiden würden wir
uns nicht einlassen wird auch keine
gespräche für die partei mit der wir am
wenigsten anfangen kann von der uns am
meisten trend ist sicher die afc ich
will nichts mit einem rechtsextremisten
und rechtspopulisten zu tun haben der
aber eine sehr gute grundlage
wir können auch unsere zukunft so
gestalten dass sie erfolgreich ist bei
der frage der energiewende der
verkehrswende der agrarwende müssen wir
weiter arbeiten gerade bei der
verkehrswende ist das dringend dringend
nötig eines der drängendsten probleme
ist in hessen natürlich der mangel an
bezahlbarem wohnraum da muss ich
dringend was ändern wir brauchen
unbedingt mehr erzieher in den
kindertagesstätten damit unsere kinder
fit sind für die schule bessere
verbindung von stadt und land arbeit und
bildung müssen zurück in den ländlichen
raum ja gut die freien demokraten wenn
wahrscheinlich nicht dem islam
ministerpräsident stellen nicht minister
bleibe dann nehme ich die
ernennungsurkunde entgegen
ein ministerpräsident müsste die
ernennungsurkunde überreichen